Oh Justine what's this a Nintendo switch
you say this isn't just any Nintendo
switch this antenna switch inside of
here is basically the embodiment of my
soul inside of this box as you guys know
one of my favorite color combinations is
camouflage especially when it comes to
pink camouflage I have been such a huge
fan of color where and when I saw them
tweak this out I about freaked out not
only did I freak out but all of you guys
freaked out you treated me this music
just seen this is something that you
need so let's open this thing up and
take a look this is a surprise this is
not something that I was expecting holy
moly what I love about color wear is
it's not really like a sticker like this
is actually printed on to the plastic I
have my other no service which here and
I've had these on since pretty much I
got this thing these are the original
NES controllers this thing looks so
great the little name is on it even
custom painted a little extra piece to
their attention to detail is incredible
they even did the dock this is a day to
remember we could hit cry I shouldn't
cry I should cry I can't cry I can grab
them once you I can get emotional about
my introduced with it let's check out
the toy cons this is just so
unbelievable
what do I even say what do I say I've
nothing to say I've absolutely nothing
to say other than this is perfect it is
the most perfect thing that I've ever
seen one of the things that's not
perfect agendas which you put these
joique on slides on the wrong side it is
so insane tick it off
it looks so perfect you guys believe it
a little link in the description guys
but i check this out and they have so
many amazing things on their website
like I'm such a huge fan you guys also
might remember a video that I did a
while ago it was these vintage air pods
that was also bicolor where they just do
really great quality work
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies thank you for watching I just
wanted to give you guys a little
unboxing of this because I was so
excited the fact that they put my name
on this it's completely unexpected that
was not something that I thought was
gonna happen at all so thank you color
where you guys are so awesome I cannot
wait to play with this thing let me know
in the comments below what games you
guys are currently playing on switch I
just downloaded the lego movie to when I
say that I'm obsessed with like a movie
like I can't even express to you like
how many times I saw the first felt like
I saw it probably over seventy five
times maybe even more actually because I
used to watch it every night before bed
I did a playthrough of the game several
times I know I played through the
entirety of it on Xbox I think back in
the day I played it on Wii U and then I
played it on Nintendo 3ds super excited
to play the next game anyway that's it
thanks for watching also if you guys are
new here or if you're not new here I
started doing a little membership thing
so there's a little join button if you
want to check that out
I like losing some high-res images of
this on my Members Only forum so if you
guys are a part of that look out for
those very very soon so with that I will
see you guys very very shortly and to
ijr me members I will see you guys in
the comments in the forums I would see
you soon I anybody still been playing
overcooked
because I started playing it again and
that game is just such an incredible
incredible game but it makes me so
[Music]
[Applause]